a very good evening well for the first
time this evening the National Grid
activated its scheme to reward customers
for using less energy the scheme allows
26 energy suppliers to offer their
customers the demand flexibility service
provided that they're signed up and have
an up-to-date smart meter and on this
special program we'll be speaking to
those who have been taking part and look
ahead to have schemes like this may
shape the future of energy consumption
in Britain well our climate change and
energy correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
joins me now from a household in
Hertfordshire which has taken part in
the scheme hi there Hannah well how did
it go
well this is the luazon household and I
can tell you the whole though of course
it looks like a totally normal home
about an hour ago it didn't they were
doing some unusual things they'd turned
off all the appliances they turned off
the boiler because this household is one
of around a million homes signed up to
the demand flexibility service which
essentially pays people to use less
electricity at peak times now the
National Grid hopes that a decent
proportion of that one Million number
will have participated this evening
we'll find out more about that in the
coming days but this is a really
significant moment in the UK's energy
story there have been several tests of
the demand flexibility service in the
past couple of months tonight is the
first time it's been used in Anger the
main reason is that the National Grid
systems operator had a look at the
forecast tonight and thought that the
gap between supply and demand would be
too small it's very cold we haven't got
as much wind as perhaps we might
normally have this time of year we've
had some reduced capacity for importing
electricity as well so the demand
flexibility service essentially helps
the National Grid to avoid controlled
blackouts this is about more than just
keeping the lights on this is about
preparing for a future this is about
preparing for a future where our world
is increasingly electrified where we
have electrified heating systems in our
home and we drive electric vehicles and
we're increasingly consumers are going
to have to be and perhaps even want to
be more flexible and Savvy about the how
they consume electricity so demand
flexibility service is a step forward on
that journey I was here in this home
when they were participating in that
service and here's how it went
I think it's really important that
everyone plays their part in Saving
electricity doing as much as we can and
I think it's important that my children
understand that electricity is not
Limitless and endless and we all we all
do our best so tell me a bit about how
you've done it what do you switch off
well we switch off virtually everything
we have the lights on in the room that
we're in all the other lights off in the
house are are off we have our oven off
we have our microwave off we keep
obviously our fridge freezer turned on
all the plugs are off
um and we're sort of sitting enjoying
non-electric things so no cooking until
later cooking no absolutely so you're
going to have a look at your smart meter
absolutely show the weight
so into the dark we go
so this is our smart meter and it's
showing what we're using today so so far
one pound 40 is worth of electricity and
1.84 worth of gas not bad pretty good I
would say and you can see our budget
line there so we're below budget and how
much do you expect to save how much have
you been saving by doing this so
actually we've got better and better
each time and which shows that we're
making progress which is great as a
teacher
um so I think we started off fairly low
with just a couple of pounds we did a
two hour saving session where we saved
actually a significant amount about 10
pounds
um so we're getting better and better
and learning as we go what are you
finding are the main appliances to not
use so definitely the oven which is
sapping electricity without us realizing
it
um and the microwave was also um using a
lot of electricity without us knowing it
and so the first session we didn't
actually turn the oven off and we
learned from that mistake and we've
turned off ever since we've done really
well with it no washing or drying
clothes presumably absolutely no no none
of those big appliances all the
televisions are turned off as well the
switches and unplugged
um
to the olden days and is the rest of the
house dark as well absolutely so show me
of course so we only have the lights on
in the Wonder in the winter in
so what do your family make of this
um so some of them think that uh we're
very brave especially the ones who've
got young children who like to be on
screens
um but a lot of them actually admire
what we're doing and I've got a lot of
friends who admire what we're doing and
actually I've got one friend who
recently bought a new microwave and has
not turned on because she's sort of
Taken inspiration from our energy saving
so you've been inspiring other people to
do the same thing I'd like to think so
so no television no television
absolutely not no off for the saving
sessions are your kids are allowed iPads
if they've already been charged up they
have to be up they have to be charged
beforehand so they have to remember to
do that before the saving session starts
um and actually some of the televisions
that we've turned off have actually
stayed off after the session because we
found that we haven't needed to turn
them back on so we've kept saving off
the saver session as well somewhat
we're joined Now by Caroline who just
saw in that video all the lights are
back on now or most of them anyway how
do you think you did
well I think we did okay we won't know
for a few days but we did all the things
that we normally do we turned everything
off we sat here and played games we had
a really positive experience so
hopefully we'll have made quite a few
octo points and hopefully more than last
time so those are the points that you
get credited by your energy provider at
roughly what's the pound value because
you've done it for a few times now
haven't you so you've done five six
sessions all together how much it does
it is so we've done six sessions and
over those six sessions we've earned
just over 20 pounds in in monetary value
I was interested to hear that you've
turned your boiler off because obviously
that uses a lot of electricity
um does that make a really big
difference I think quite a lot of people
are worried that this might mean people
are sitting in the cold in the dark how
have you found it to be no I think that
actually that's not been an issue at all
um obviously we have five in our
families there's lots of heat from us as
people
um and we just make sure that we are in
a place where the heat is
um
exactly and um you know if we need to
have a bit of a snuggle then we have a
cuddle and keep each other warm what's
your main motivation for this is it to
do with climate change or is it mainly
to do with bills I think it's both I
think you know
um we are um taking advantage of getting
credit against our account and that's
brilliant in this cost of living crisis
but at the same time we are trying to
help the planet in a in a little way
albeit
um everyone's got to do their bit and
and this is our bit National Grid is
going to do another one of these we've
just heard tomorrow night between 4 30
and 6. that's the crucial after school
period and you've got small children
will you participate
I think so I think that um if we can
work our lives around this saver session
then there's no reason for us not to
sign up so yes we will be signing up
Caroline razon thank you very much well
there you have it a little snapshot of
one household who's participated in
demand flexibility service over several
months and uh they're real converts I
think it's fair to say and they're going
to try again to do the same thing to use
a less electricity during peak time
tomorrow night okay Hannah many thanks
and we're going to stay with that theme
households that have been participating
in the scheme and uh head north there
and there he is Gary Alleman who's also
been taking part in the demand
flexibility service very good to see you
there Gary have you warmed up yet
yeah yeah yes we've had the um gas fire
on so we're quite warm now
and what do you do while you're
participating in the scheme how do you
stay warm is it is it blankets or what
no the best we're join you for an hour
and like I say we have the room heated
up beforehand and then basically
everything's just switched off and then
you just sit we switch the iPads on just
like Karen said in the last interview
um television gets switched off all the
iPads are charged up and the kettle's
boiled ready for a hot one so yeah
everything's covered ah you've got it
all sorted you because of course you've
done it before haven't you
yes this will be our seventh time
um we've been paid on five of the other
occasions and we've earned about 14
pounds fifty and we've got two to be
weight on and Eon who were with a really
good um the let us know two minutes past
six we've got an email saying being
successful in today's
um uh saving and Dale um then credit us
account in about 72 hours
so you saved in total about 14 pounds
does that make a difference then to the
household budget
anything makes a difference yes
definitely
um I mean this was an invite from me on
I just think a lot more people should be
invited under this scheme because it's
important for families and with children
as well definitely I mean do you have
children Gary
no minor grown upper away
um I don't that's just me and my wife so
we find it quite easy this um energy
saving scheme because sometimes we'll go
for a walk and we're out while while
it's on and nothing's switched on to be
honest so yeah yeah I mean you know dare
I said is it something you quite look
forward to because you you do something
different you turn everything off
presumably you then talk to each other
or as you say you go for a walk
yeah we do we we engage we have a little
bit of talk we can go on the iPad so you
know and we'll put when it's dark nice
like this we have a little camp light
and we switch that on it makes a little
bit cozy and then we just get snuggled
up we just have a chat you know so it's
it's really good and without the
incentives I mean are you still learning
and deploying good habits are you trying
to cut down on your energy consumption
because even with the government help it
still costs an awful lot doesn't it of
course it does
um it focuses you more on on things you
know things are important like showers
we switch to having showers in the
winter rather than baths and the
immersion heat that like the Karen was
saying it's expensive to heat up through
the night
um and yeah yeah just it just you just
pick things the kettle by Locale four
cups rather than just a cup and it keeps
it for later on you know so yeah
it focuses your mind
and uh just one more question Gary I
suppose the big question is these have
all been pre-planned plenty of notice
and you say you've been able to make the
preparations in terms of boiling the
kettle and whatever else it is you do
but I mean we might reach a situation
when you've got you know half an hour or
an hour's notice and it's quick because
you know some serious shortages are
going to happen if um we don't dampen
down demand would you be prepared to
react more quickly
definitely definitely
yeah if it saves the grid and everything
like that yeah
um I think my main thing is for a lot
more people to get tied into this
because I think this is the future
Poise and ready to respond Gary element
very good to see you enjoy your evening
there's another one tomorrow isn't there
I'm sure you you're going to take it
yeah yeah
okay Gary thanks very much indeed best
of luck thanks a lot cheers
well now the deployment of the scheme
comes at a time when many people are
keeping a closer eyes Gary says they're
on their outgoings and energies so how
do consumers stand to benefit from
schemes like lead demand flexibility
scheme while joining me now is Will
Hodson consumer champion and how to save
it a campaign that helps people save
money on bills by improving their Energy
Efficiency very good to see you well I
mean your reaction to to these schemes
they're obviously been rolled out that
have happened already as we heard from
Carol and my guest there but they're
obviously going to become more of a
feature absolutely I think doing this
well is going to be part of the job
description for future energy companies
it seems like it's a very clever idea as
a matter of fact you know people
remember time of use tariffs eco7 the
chat that you know the truth is energy
is cheaper to generate at certain times
of day so it should be cheaper to use at
certain times of day as well and do you
think then people are as Gary Oliver was
saying there even without the incentive
learning good habits because the less
you use even when you're not getting a
discount or an incentive to do it the
more you save obviously the absolutely
iron it goes back to basics you know
it's about getting your habits right
first it's getting the right habits
costs nothing but longer term to reduce
our bills and you need to actually get
to your beyond the habits and actually
start to make those modifications to
your house and after that you look at
your heating devices but that's where
you need government help as well so I
think we're entering this era where
we're asking everyone to do their bit
but companies and government have got to
be smart enough to know people are going
to say I want to do my bit
but what's in it for me what about
though I mean the last prime minister
wasn't too keen on government
information schemes to encourage people
and just give people simple tips she
thought you know there were some
sections of of government that think
well that's Nanny statism it may be but
does it make sense to you I think
there's no time for Dogma in the energy
situation that we're in now you can have
your age-old principles but in age-old
you know times ago you didn't have the
government effectively paying half of
every Energy bill in the land that was
more or less a situation that the energy
price guarantee put the British taxpayer
in and I think it's incumbent on
government once you've said we're going
to Bear the brunt of bills up and down
the land to at least show us how we
might use a little bit less energy not
only does it save us money as Bill
payers it can end up saving taxpayers
the British government billions of
pounds as well well let's grade them up
then I mean what are the simple things
people can do and do they really save
much money you know attending they'll
light off or turning off of planters
that are on standby again let's start
with habits then you move on to home
with habits there are things like
switching stuff off at the wall if you
possibly can turning your thermostat
down by one degree can save you hundreds
of pounds over a year then basic
efficiency things that one's
grandparents could have taught you right
only use the washing machine when it's
full only boil a kettle when it's full
and it's off the washing machine when
it's full so much for habits but really
to bring down your your bills you need
to look at what your home is
contributing now Derm I've got to tell
you Britain has got the oldest housing
stock in Europe and weekly proud of
having Built Homes are made to last but
well previous generations built them
that's it and we can be happy about them
proud of them it's part of our
architectural Heritage however they are
the draftiest homes in Europe they cost
the most to heat and the fact is Britain
is overdue a national insulation scheme
I would encourage anyone out there he's
feeling a bit of heat you know Going
Through the Windows going through the
ceiling to get in touch with their
Energy company who has an obligation an
obligation no less to help vast millions
of households to insulate their homes
better there was a time that I just I've
got to ask you about that obligation a
lot of people might not know about that
I mean is that an obligation monetarily
to help people the financial
contribution that's right they're a
grant so as of April 2023 Eco plus the
energy obligation plus will come into
play now what that means is NG companies
have got grants and an obligation to
hand out grants to households to install
the most simple insulation and the most
effective insulation to the homes now is
there a means test for that it's not
available to everyone it was previously
means tested but the accessibility has
been broadened out so if you're in a
council tax ban from a to d in England I
think it's a to e in Wales but don't
hold me to it it's worth getting in
touch with your Energy company company
with your Energy company they might give
you free installation that ends up
saving you hundreds of pounds per year
well that really does need more
publicity doesn't it absolutely you
might say damn it that putting energy
companies who rely on selling units of
energy in charge of Energy Efficiency
rollout is a bit like putting turkeys in
charge of rolling out Christmas but get
in touch I don't want to start the
conspiracy theory get in touch and they
can probably help you in a big way I
mean from what you're saying there you
know the campaign group insulate Britain
are not wrong people may disagree with
their tactics but but they're not wrong
are they they should I mean if there
were a a mass campaign to do that it
would generate huge savings in terms of
electricity and of course create jobs
yeah I mean you can have a debate about
where it's right to sit down in a road
in front of oncoming traffic but I don't
think there's any debate at all about
the desirability of installing
insulation which is going to reduce your
bills
reduce your carbon emissions and
possibly create jobs in parts of the
country where it's badly needed as well
I think that's something that we as a
country should get behind last question
then about you know boilers and and heat
pumps that's we've gone from the one end
of the scale right the way to the top
you know if all the inefficient gas
boilers were to be replaced that would
cost billions I imagine that's right and
I mean the government's got a scheme in
place to do that boiler upgrade scheme I
think we shouldn't be putting too much
focus on that again we are on a journey
it starts with habits then it goes to
insulating your home once you've got a
more energy efficient home you're going
to take that final step towards getting
an airsource heat pump which is going to
be a much cheaper way to keep yourself
warm through the winter okay well will
Hudson very good to get your tips and
your analysis thank you very very much
indeed very good to see for this uh
special news tonight program on energy
well the National Grid had previously
come close to activating the demand
flexibility service during last months
cold spell but the decision to use the
scheme today and tomorrow comes not
necessarily as a result of cold weather
but actually from problems being faced
elsewhere our science correspondent
Thomas Moore now explains
this has been the biggest energy crunch
so far this winter with electricity
Supply meeting Demand only through
Extraordinary Measures but paying
consumers to reduce their consumption
National Grid hope to reduce demand
across the country by 337 megawatts
that's about a third of the output of a
gas power station so it's not much but
it's enough to get the country through
anticipated Peak demand between 5 and 6
PM so let's look at the situation at 5
30 then well the UK was using just over
45 gigawatts of electricity 55 was
coming from gas and coal and 24 from
Renewables and nuclear now that's not
that unusual and whether it can't take
all of the blame it's cold but not that
cold in fact Scotland is relatively mild
is certainly nothing like the freezing
conditions Before Christmas it's also
windier now than it was in the last cold
spell these stronger winds shown in
green and yellow are helping to generate
just under six gigawatts of electricity
from wind farms in the North Sea on
December the 12th wind generation was
around one and a quarter so it's not as
cold as it has been this winter and our
turbines are turning so what is going on
then well energy analysts say it has a
lot to do with the situation in France
at the start of the month 15 of its 56
nuclear reactors were shut down for
repairs they would normally be a
reliable source of electricity that the
UK could import through cables under the
channel so electricity Supply is tight
and companies are competing for whatever
they can get you can see that in the
market price for much of the day the
wholesale cost has been around 130
pounds a megawatt hour at times of high
demand Breakfast early afternoon and the
evening the cost more than doubled but
the National Grid wasn't sure there
would be enough electricity available
during the Monday Peak even at a high
price and that's what it has for the
first time paid consumers to reduce
demand
well let's uh discuss in more depth now
some of the issues there that Thomas was
analyzing Force I'm joined Now by some
guests so just discuss the feature of
what energy looks like in the UK
including the founder and chief
executive of utility energy billboard
and the former advisor on energy policy
to Gordon Brown Nick Butler uh very good
to see you gentlemen and uh if we could
start with you Nick Butler uh nick uh
what do you make of this scheme then uh
all schemes I should say it's not the
not the first time and we know there's
going to be another one tomorrow
I think it's a very good scheme I think
uh National Grid are doing exactly the
right thing my worry would be doing it
for a million households is not enough
uh if we're going to have a really
difficult period now and I think we
might
uh I think the weather is colder across
Europe than it is in the UK tonight and
therefore there's a pool of demand for
power uh Germany is very cold this
evening and I think that that if that
continues through this week that's going
to be difficult which is I presume why
National Grid are testing this scheme
today and tomorrow there's also a risk
that the wind as you said might not blow
quite as much as we need it to blow and
we don't know the key variable is what
the Russians do next we we are still
importing gas from Russia and Mr Putin
is therefore has the ability to cut it
off to cut off supplies into Europe and
the problem for the UK is that we don't
have stocks
uh Germany and France have 25 of their
annual consumption as stocks which they
can use in times of shortage we have
just one percent yeah and I think that
while these good people who you showed
are doing the right thing and National
Grid is doing the right thing they're
still a bigger problem behind this might
not be enough okay I just want to get
the only thoughts of Bill bullon on that
they're not on the schemes first of all
do you think they are almost certainly
the shape of things to come
yeah I would say uh I would agree with
that um we actually didn't take part in
the NGC scheme we we set up our asking
the key concern we had was whether or
not the financial incentives were going
to be big enough for you know people to
take action but I think you know NGC
obviously proved that actually in some
cases certainly you don't need such a
huge uh Financial incentive and I think
what everybody's going to be doing now
is starting to gear themselves up for
next winter
um and you know we're going to see a lot
more of this uh this kind of activity
going on certainly our trial it was
which we did you know by ourselves was
very successful uh consumers definitely
responded to the price signals and you
know we we're definitely going to expand
it and I think you know every all the
suppliers have been involved in the NGC
scheme will be in the same place okay
that's an interesting point you make Mr
bullon about next winter as well I'm
joined Now by John Stern from the Oxford
Institute for energy studies has made it
into the studio with you know your
Reflections on on these schemes these
consumer facing schemes and that point
that bill bullin is making you know
we're all focused obviously on the Here
and Now on on this winter but this is a
structural a long-term issue it is a
long-term issue but probably with the
way the energy Market's shaping up this
winter and next winter are going to be
the crucial ones if we can get past
winter 2023-24 you wouldn't be
completely complacent after that but you
say things should get easier but yes
these schemes that are the way of things
to come with digitization we should be
able to do this in a much more
streamlined way and once consumers get
used to this and adjust to it quickly I
think it'll be you know really very
successful and it's a better idea than
constantly trying to find new Supply
trying to cut demand is really a good
way to go well and also as I was
discussing with my previous guests one
another way of cutting demand is of
course improving the efficiency of
appliances delivering heat for instance
to homes and of course insulating them
no absolutely and it's a shame we've
done so little about that in the UK over
the last decade because most Continental
European countries are far ahead of us
in terms of conservation and efficiency
indeed and Professor Butler then let's
look for further ahead and um do you go
along with the point being made there by
Johnstone that we're not necessarily
going to be looking for supplies from
elsewhere we we have to make sure we we
make the most of what we've got and and
generate more of it domestically
I I think we have to do both for the
moment we're still as some of your
graphics showed we're still dependent on
gas and we import half the gas we use
that is not going to change totally even
if we're very efficient in the way we
use energy so we have to make sure we're
getting the supplies I think we have to
make sure we're getting the stocks but I
certainly agree with Jonathan that we
should be pursuing efficiency wherever
we can and it's it's shame that the
government here has not matched what the
government in Germany and elsewhere in
Europe government's Germany and
elsewhere have done which is to just
encourage people over the last few
months to cut their consumption by at
least 15 and if we did that uh the
situation would be much better this
winter and next round okay Bill Bolin
you're nodding along to that but
governments need to do much more than
that as well and don't they have to
think long term and the governments that
come after them have to have to stick
with those plans when it comes to energy
Supply you can't conjure these things up
quickly
absolutely no but what I would say is
you know as an energy Supply we've seen
probably at least a 15 reduction in
energy consumption this year just you
know not after allowing for you know any
weather effects we've seen about a 15
reduction in energy consumption so
consumers have been uh cutting back on
energy consumption and that may be a
good thing it may actually be a bad
thing because obviously in some cases
that may be consumers who are not uh
consuming because they can't afford it
um but I absolutely agree with you know
previous speakers will Hoster them and
the others you know that the first step
has got to be about reducing consumption
and we've got an awful long way to go
and you know so it's a bit of chalk and
cheese red if you compare with what's
going on in the UK compared with say uh
Germany where you know they're almost
celebrating the reductions in energy
consumption government buildings have
also been you know really tasked with
reducing energy consumption and the
other thing that we've seen in Germany
is a huge swing away from Russian gas
Germany was by far and away the most
dependent European country on Russian
gas and the investment and the speed
with which they're switched their gas
supplies and it is still gas but um to
other sources LNG for example they've
built two new LNG Terminals and there's
another four on the way I believe so
okay we have the other European
countries act I think you know much more
decisively and you know much more
quickly in you know diversifying their
energy sources and therefore you know
security that I mean John Cena I want to
ask you taking that on board then you
know the mistakes or perhaps make that's
too strong a word that are being made
here in the United Kingdom why do you
think then things get better two three
years down the line in terms of energy
Supply well principally because we're
not so worried about gas supplies we'll
have more Global LNG supplies on online
by then again I don't want to sound too
complacent because because essentially
it's 2027 when a huge amount of new
Global LNG comes on so we're not
completely out of the wood in 20 25 26.
what just explain to people what is
going on right now what's deliver that
guy what is what's happened you see is
that we it this is a very lumpy industry
we all invest at the same time and then
we all don't invest so at the time when
prices were extremely low which people
have now forgotten 2019 and 2020 uh
price were extremely low during covid uh
what happened was nobody invested
because they couldn't see that they'd
make any money suddenly as prices went
up in 2021-22 everyone has invested in
new Global LNG Supply and so these these
these projects take four or five years
to come on SO in 2026-27 we have a lot
of global LNG Supply coming on and we
will then be even if there is no Russian
gas coming to Europe will be relatively
relaxed I think there will be still some
Russian guests coming to Europe the
problem has been as your previous
speaker was saying that we suddenly we
lost 80 percent of our Russian gas in
Europe and we we scrambling to create
new uh facilities to import liquefied
natural gas and and the Germans have
done that the Dutch have done that the
Italians are on the way to doing that
um but we here
um I've got a lot of LNG import capacity
and we've been supplying that been
importing it ourselves and then
supplying it to the content but I mean
of course it all begs the the climate
question Professor Butler doesn't it
they're all all well and good if we're
going to get plenty of gas being
imported from sources other than Russia
in a couple of years time but it does
nothing to reduce our emissions you know
we're just offshoring it and in the end
don't we domestically have to get more
General operation coming from yes wind
yes solar but also nuclear
uh yes that's true I think the key step
now is to Electrify more of the economy
so electricity uh supplies only 20 of
our final demand and uh if we were able
to raise that to 30 or 40 percent by
electrifying things such as the railways
uh and Home Heating uh over time that
would make the real difference what we
have to do is think about today tomorrow
and the day after tomorrow for today and
tomorrow we still need gas and we should
make sure we have it we should use it as
efficiently as possible and in parallel
with that we should be planning a move
away from gas over 5 10 15 years but can
I just ask hear me with that
electrification program you recommend of
course that then increases Demand yet
again where's it going to come from
oh I think over time you can move to
Renewables and eventually we might have
some new nuclear uh but I think this the
energy mix in this country changes
gradually it doesn't change overnight we
are still going to need gas for the
foreseeable future Bill Bowen is that
your analysis
yeah I would agree with that I mean the
the challenge really is how we Electrify
transport and Home Heating now those are
the big areas but obviously um if
everybody was driving an electric car
then uh domestic energy domestic
electricity consumption is going to be
massively higher so you know we have to
invest you know right across the board
it's not just in new power sources but
it's also in the you know the wires that
are connecting people's homes to the
grid
um you know there's there's an awful lot
of investment and my concern to be
honest with you is how are we going to
pay for that because at the moment you
know we've got a regulator that doesn't
want to see Energy prices going up we've
got a chance there who doesn't want to
see taxes going up and we've got a money
market that doesn't seem to want to lend
us any money so you know there's a real
challenge here for the UK economy to get
down this Pathway to Net Zero and we've
got to somehow crack the way that we're
gonna fund it well listen a fascinating
conversation thank you all Bill Bowen
Nick Butler and John Stern here with me
in the studio thank you all very much
Judy for joining us on this Sky News
Tonight special program